welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar validation and
implementation of quantitative molecular
assays it is presented by Morgan pence
PhD the director of clinical and
molecular microbiology at Cook
Children's Medical Center in Fort Worth
Texas my name is Judy O'Rourke and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's and sponsored by Diaz soaring
molecular for more information about our
sponsor visit molecular dias orrin calm
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers a
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now about further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. pence I will
now turn the presentation over to her
thank you for the introduction and I'm
excited to be here today to talk to you
about validation and implementation of
quantitative molecular assays it's a bit
of a dry topic but very important for
everything we do in the lab so I'll
focus a lot on the regulatory
requirements for that for my disclosures
I am receiving compensation for this
presentation and I have received
research reagents from DSS or molecular
in the past however this information
presented in this talk is of my own
opinion and not that of dias or
molecular nor of my employer Cook
Children's Medical Center the learning
objectives for today are first to define
verification and validation and then to
define the verification requirements for
unmodified FDA cleared or fda-approved
tests we'll follow that with a
discussion of the validation
requirements for modified fda-cleared
tests and laboratory developed tests and
then talk about the calibration methods
and standards that are required for
quantitative assays so I first want to
start with kind of a definition or
overview of the regulatory agencies
we'll be talking about and CLIA is one
that we all hear about was actually
developed in 1988 by the Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid for CMS so they're
really the agency but we talk about CLIA
which are the clinical laboratory
Improvement Amendments which define and
regulate all laboratory testing all
clinical testing that's performed on
humans in the US and if you're
interested the actual clear regulations
can be found in what's called the Code
of Federal Regulations which are u.s.
government documents and you can
actually view all of the clear
requirements online by googling CFR I
also put a link in the one of my last
slides with resources as well in case
you're interested
so another agency is Kapoor the College
of American Pathologists and they're a
laboratory accreditation program so they
have a list of standards or requirements
to make sure that labs are performing
testing appropriately and many of their
top standards or the cap standards are
based off of clear regulations and at
least meet minimum CLIA regulations and
sometimes are more stringent than clear
regulations as well
so when we talk about laboratory testing
we're focusing mostly on non waved
laboratory tests right so wave tests are
things that are easy have minimal harm
to patients such as things that are used
in the point-of-care environment but
we're primarily focused on non wave
tests so I want to just discuss kind of
the breakdown of these different
definitions so fda-cleared is an
fda-approved or a test that the FDA has
determined is substantially equivalent
to another already approved device or
test and so this is referred to as a 510
K approval
there's also FDA approved so often FDA
cleared an FDA approved are used
interchangeably but they actually have
slightly different definitions so FDA
approved is where it has received a pre
approval for a pre-market approval
application and this is a more rigorous
application for the FDA than a 510 K so
for the most part these are used
interchangeably and really the fine
hairs of the differences don't matter so
much
there's also FDA modified which is where
you take either of these types of tests
cleared or approve and you modify it in
the laboratory and we'll talk about
different modifications in a little bit
and then there are laboratory developed
tests which are tests that are developed
wholly or in part by the performing
laboratory and this may include analyte
specific regions or ASRs which are
reagents such as primers and probes sets
that are sold by manufacturers and used
to develop a test in the lab so
historically a lot of labs would design
our own primers and probes but
technology has advanced a lot of these
can be purchased from manufacturers and
in regards to validation requirements
for what we're concerned about in the
lab with bringing a new test FDA
modified tests and El DTS are considered
the same so I've had people tell me or
try and argue in the past that because
the test was was FDA cleared it's okay
they don't have to do a stringent of a
validation as a laboratory test
laboratory developed tests but actually
as soon as you modify it becomes
off-label and treated like an LD T and
we will talk about that as well
so let's define verification validation
and this is actually a little bit
confusing because different groups have
different definitions so as defined by
CLIA or the government verification is a
one-time process a prior to
implementation of assay where you're
demonstrating that that test performs as
expected and their definition of
validation is an ongoing process to
confirm that the test continues to
perform as expected so I would say most
people do not use these definitions but
instead more refer to the cap
definitions so cap defines verification
as the process by which a lab determines
an unmodified fda-cleared test performs
according to the manufacturers package
insert and validation is basically the
same thing except you're showing that a
laboratory developed tests or an
modified FDA test approves or performs
as it should and so these are used often
interchangeably they're they're pretty
close in meaning but verification is
basically when you're bringing in an
unmodified fda-cleared test and
validation is if you're bringing in a
laboratory developed tests or modified
fda-cleared test so which one is correct
validation and verification are used
interchangeably and primarily when
laboratory ins are talking about these
processes they're talking about the
initial process that is done when the
test is brought in to ensure that it
performs as expected and what CLIA
defines as validation is primarily what
laboratory ins refer to as quality
insurance which is once the laboratory
has validated or verified in assay we
then make sure the and that the test
performs as expected as we continue to
run it and perform patient testing so
quality assurance measures include
quality control proficiency testing
calibration verification and analytical
measurement range verification and we'll
talk a little bit more about those
towards the end of the talk
so as far as what's required when it
comes to verification and validation and
we're going to focus when talking about
verification validation on the cap
definitions so laboratories are required
to perform this initial verification or
validation before the test is used in
patient testing so you can't you know
bring it in and start testing patients
and then ensure that it's performing
well and this is required for any non
wave test a new test method or a new
instrument so even if you you know run a
CMV quant if you bring in a new platform
you have to validate that and cap
specifically states that not only does
this include instruments of the same
make and model but also loaner
instrument so something happens to your
instrument and the manufacturer gives
you a loaner instrument you actually
have to validate that as well and
there's no exception for tests
introduced prior to a specific date so
if you have a test that was introduced
you know back in maybe the early 2000s
you still have to have verification or
validation records for that as well in
regards to FDA modified test what is it
that constitutes a lot of fication
and basically it's anything or any
modification that's made to the package
insert and these include things such as
specimen source so if the test is only
FDA cleared for CSF but you want to
validate it in-house for blood and be al
to death patient specimens
now that's FDA modified or off-label and
its treated as a lab develop test this
also includes things like pooling
specimens diluting specimens changing
the collection device so if it's
approved for universal transport media
and you want to use m4 which is a
different type of viral transport media
that's off label patient populations so
there's some tests out there that are
not FDA cleared for patients under 14
for example so if you type that patient
population it's off-label and also
instrument changes so if you have a
quantitative molecular assay that is FDA
cleared for use for example with the
Roche Magna pure instrument but you want
to use
the Bo marry you easy mag that's
off-label as well and as I mentioned a
little bit ago FDA modified tests are
considered the same as LD TS when we're
talking about laboratory regulatory
standards
and once you modify a test the reason
why it becomes similar to an LD T is
because it's now outside of the
fda-cleared scope so when companies
submit assays to the FDA for clearance
they're very defined and have very
defined criteria and specifications but
once you change a specimen source are
pooling now you've changed the intent in
the scope of that assay so it is more
similar to a laboratory developed tests
and in addition once you modify it any
test it becomes high complexity so if
you are using an FDA cleared test that's
considered moderate complexity and
you're using it off-label it's now
automatically high complexity which
changes the personnel requirements as
well
so before you start your verification
validation process you want to determine
what specimen types will be included
right so are you going to use it
off-label are you going to stick to the
package insert or what not and
specifically when you're thinking about
blood you can't be so nonspecific so
right we think about quantitative
molecular assays and blood is one of the
when the main specimen type that they're
used for but you really have to define
this as is it whole blood is a plasma or
is a serum and then if you're going to
validate plasma or verify plasma you
must must define which type of plasma
right so we generally in microbiology or
molecular microbiology think of purple
tops with EDTA plasma but there's also
different types as well such as those
with acid citrate dextrose and also
lithium and sodium heparin but those are
used not used typically for PCR because
of the inhibitory effects of the heparin
it's important to note what you're
validating as well because viral loads
may be significantly different between
blood sources so for viral loads for
things like see em being EBV we see
significant differences between whole
blood and plasma so you want to make
sure you know what you're validating and
stick with that the specific
requirements for verification validation
are listed here and these are pulled
from the cap checklist so if you are
verifying an FDA approved non-modified
test so you haven't changed anything in
the package insert you have to include
accuracy precision reportable range
reference range and analytical
sensitivity or limit of detection for
that assay and we'll go through these
each in more details now as far as
defined actually by CLIA you don't have
to do analytical sensitivity but cap has
said that for quantitative test that you
actually do have to do the limit of
detection so that is an extra
requirement for cap
for FDA modified or lab developed test
you have to do the same thing as the FDA
approved non modified test but also test
analytical specificity or interferences
and the cap standards that refer to each
of these are listed in the column on the
right so if you want to refer to the
different checklist these are from the
all common checklist and the
microbiology checklist if you want more
details as well in addition to those
specific requirements there are also a
couple of more requirements so one is
that the instrument must be verified or
validated in a location in which patient
testing will be performed so if it's
moved
if you validate it in one place and move
it somewhere else you have to determine
if that will affect the performance of
the essay and so cap is a little bit
gray on this and they don't give
definitions of you know if it's moved
over 25 feet to a new building they
don't specifically say but the lab is
responsible for determining if they move
it if it may affect the performance of
the assay and if it does then you'll
have to Rivera Phi or revalidate and so
as an example for this we actually moved
labs a new new tower and a hospital was
built a couple of years ago and we moved
and it was a completely different kind
of building or section in the hospital
and so we revalidated rivera fide all of
our assays for each verification or
validation that's performed in the lab
there must be an evaluation that's
signed by the laboratory director prior
to use and so what this is is a summary
we also in our lab put all of the data
with that as well and a binder and then
that must be retained as long as the
test is in use and for at least two
years after a test is discontinued so
make sure you have all those documented
and then some cap inspectors come in and
like to look at the validation
verification summaries
so those are the general kind of
requirements and overview as far as
verification validation but let's move
into more specifically discussing
verification validation of quantitative
molecular assays so step one is
calibration once you've decided you know
this assay and the platform that you're
going to use you want to do calibration
so there should be an image here I'm not
sure if it's showing up but this
calibration is establishment under
certain conditions between the
instrument response and the
corresponding concentration of an
analyte so if your analyte is 500 is
that what is being reported by the
instrument and the lab must have defined
procedures for calibration and so
there's our curve program and it doesn't
necessarily say cap doesn't define what
that process has to be but just instead
says that the lab has to have specific
procedures that define how they're going
to perform calibration and on the right
here is a calibration curve shown from
one that we've run for one of our UV
quantized
when you're deciding you know when
you're getting ready to do your
calibration curve or your standard curve
there is a decision about what materials
to use so if you're using an FDA
approved or cleared assay the
manufacturer should have instruction for
those on how you calibrate it and what
specific materials you use and often
those are provided by the manufacturer
for FDA modified tests or loud develop
tests especially those using a SRS
you'll want to purchase materials as
well so you want high quality materials
that have test system and matrix
appropriate target values and matrix is
referring to your specific source so
plasma CSF etc
so calibration materials are available
from the manufacturer often for
fda-approved tests or third-party
vendors as well and I want to make the
point to all calibration materials are
not equivalent so you know there's lots
of CMV calibration panels out there for
example but the reliability and
repeatability is not always consistent
so there are some manufacturers that
have more robust calibration panels than
others and it's important to use high
quality calibration materials that have
less variability so that your assay is
consistent and you don't run into any QC
failures or any issues with variation in
your as a reporting
calibration materials should contain
whole virus in matrix appropriate
materials and so this is to be the most
closely related to a patient specimen as
possible so you have it mimicking your
human specimens so some calibration
panels are true EDTA plasma where others
are approaching matrices that mimic a
specimen so that's something to keep in
mind and if you are using one that has
protein matrices does it does it
adequately mimic it does it perform well
so something to keep in mind when
comparing that and you know you could
also talk to your colleagues your
clinical colleagues for recommendations
on which which manufacturers provide
high quality materials or try them
yourself or there are some references in
the literature looking at performance
and comparing these against one another
so now that you have materials picked
out you want to know does your platform
allowed for a stored standard curve so
can you make a calibration or put
together a calibration curve and then
store it and continually use it each day
if not and some instrument platforms
require you to perform a calibration
each day and so then you'll need to just
create a new standard curve each day of
testing
when you're creating your standard curve
you'll want to run your calibrators
anywhere in duplicate to sex supplicant
which is six replicates some FDA
approved tests require these only to be
run in singlet but a lot of times you
know we'll run ours if we're creating a
new calibration curve insect sex
supplicant just to make sure we have you
know a lot of replicates to make sure we
have an accurate curve and detect the
variability that may be there
and you may want to consider running
more replicates for the lowest or the
lowest to calibrators because in general
we see more variation at the lower end
of the curve and that can help you kind
of detect the greater variability there
so second table Kate sometimes
potentially even more
once you have then run your calibrators
and created your standard curve you want
to perform what's called regression
analysis and this may be performed
automatically by the test system for FDA
approved or cleared tests and may say
this meets the requirements and accept
it otherwise you'll likely have to
analyze it yourself and determine if it
is a good fit or not is it a good curve
to use and if not you'll want to then
recalibrate so in regards to what to
analyze there's a few different things
you want to look at and this is one of
our curves here this is actually a
really beautiful curve they don't always
look this nice but it is a nice example
so if you remember I don't remember for
this grade school or middle middle
school but we learned about y equals MX
plus B which is the equation for a line
and M equals your slope and B equals
your bias and then r-squared is another
point that will be analyzed and this is
your coefficient of determination which
will assess the fit of the curve so your
r-squared should be as close to 1 as
possible or a hundred percent so if you
can see at the top of the graph on the
right the r-squared is 0.99 so 99% so
that's a very good fit so some people
will you know think oh you just look at
the r-squared and you're done if you
have a good r-squared but that's not
true sometimes you can get a good
r-squared but still not a very good
curve so in addition you want to look at
slope so that M and it should be close
to 1 so in this case it's one point zero
zero 4 so that's a very good slope and
then your B point which is your bias
should be close to zero so there are no
definitions of you know this is what is
an acceptable r-squared slope or bias
you just want to make sure that there is
close to 1 1 and 0 respectively as
possible and if you have a high
r-squared but your slope is not close to
1 or your bias is really high no point 8
or 1 then you'll want to run a new
and this is something you'll kind of
develop a feel for after a while but
there are no defined criteria for what
makes it acceptable
in addition you'll want to look at the
coefficient of variation which is a
measure of relative variability so we
use the dias or in molecular
quantitative assays this is one from one
of our assays I believe EBV and this is
analysis from the instrument but if you
look at the coefficient of variation on
the right aside so in the far right
column if you look for your higher
calibrators your mid-to-high calibrators
your cv should be low less than 10 to
15% ideally and your lower calibrators
you're going to have more variance your
CV zowie going to be higher and it's
recommended to keep that within twenty
to fifty percent or so so if you see
that start to creep up and 60 to 70
percent or higher you're going to run
into some issues there and that's really
just to make sure that there's not a lot
of variation in your curve and within
your assay
once you have your curve figured out
then you'll want to start running
patient specimens and with patient
specimens you'll want to run quality
control and the quality control
requirements also apply to patient
testing after you implement it and so as
far as what's required for daily quality
control is for quantitative assays it
must consist of at least three controls
so a low positive a high positive and a
negative and similar with a lot of these
things there's no definition of what
constitutes a lower high positive it's
kind of a relative term cap does
recommend that if there is a specific
cutoff value that you're using for your
assay that you use a control near that
but for a lot of these quantitative
assays there's not a defined cutoff so
for CMV quant for example there's not
necessarily an amount that determines
disease versus not disease so just
generally a low high and negative
controls must assess the adequacy of the
extraction amplification so it's
important to treat your controls as a
patient specimen so they should go
through the entire process through
extraction and amplification to control
for all steps of the test when you start
your validation or verification you'll
want to start with accuracy so accuracy
is comparison of your results by your
new method to what they're established
results were so you can either use a
reference method but a lot of times we
don't have the gold standard method
available and we're often comparing just
to another established comparative
method so an assay by another
manufacturer perhaps or from another lab
and so you're looking at how close a
test result is to the analytes true
value and you want to use matrix
appropriate materials and so preferably
for accuracy studies patient specimens
are best that may not always be possible
depending on what the assay is and
depending what your lab has available
but you can also use matrix appropriate
reference materials or other community
riyals um however cap defines
specifically that you can't use routine
quality control material or calibrators
that are used to calibrate the test so
primarily patient specimens but you can
use reference materials as well if
necessary and we'll talk about places to
get some of those in just a moment
so the big question with accuracy always
is how many samples do I have to run
what is required you know what's the
minimum I can get by way and some of the
standards say kind of more general
requirements so one of the micro
standards on the cap checklist says an
adequate number of positive and negative
specimens representing the sample types
used in the assay so that's not the most
helpful but they do say that specimens
may be spiked if patient specimens
aren't available or you don't have them
spanning the entire range so more
specifically cap does have a couple of
checklist items that refer to accuracy
for FDA approved and then FDA modified
and LD tees and for FDA approved it's
kind of like the general guidelines they
don't give a lot of guidance so they
simply say that the laboratory verifies
or establishes accuracy using a
sufficient number of characterized
samples and again that routine quality
materials are cannot be used but they
don't state how many so generally even
for our FDA approved tests we we use the
guidance from FDA modified or LD TS so
they do give specific numbers for that
and so for qualitative test it's a
minimum of twenty samples and this
includes positive negative and low
positives and when you're talking about
quantitative I will talk about
quantitative in math but this includes
positive negative and low positive
specifically for quantitative test the
number is the same it's a minimum of
twenty samples but they say that it must
span the analytical measurement range
which is basically the range of the
assay so if your assay goes from five
hundred to five million you 1/2 samples
that fall across that curve and not just
all of them falling around 50 thousand
for example and you can use mixtures of
samples if you need to to get some of
the concentrations that you need so I
will add that
app doesn't specifically say this but
this minimum of 20 samples is referring
really to the sample type so if you're
running a quantitative molecular assay
and you decide you want to do plasma and
B al and CSS for example and if you want
to run them all then you really need to
do 20 samples per specimen type so 20
plasma 20 CSS and whatnot so they don't
specifically state that but whenever
I've asked them they do say that it
really means by example type because
they're all kind of little mini
validations or you're validating each
source so that's something to keep in
mind if you don't have 20 samples and 4
things with you know assays that have
less common analytes you can use fewer
than that if you do the laboratory
director must write down and it must be
in writing the criteria that are used to
determine the appropriateness so if you
only have pen the lab director has to
kind of sign off why that's acceptable
and why why you couldn't get any more
samples so cap put these requirements as
far as the 20 specimens that was added
to their checklist in July of 2016 prior
to that they didn't state specifically
how many samples needed to be used so if
you validated an assay before that
captain agent came out you still need
some records of performance but they do
say that you can use either proficiency
testing results alternative PT you know
swapping samples between labs or quality
control to show that you may have not
had that many originally but the Year
assay is performing as expected
in a lot of cases that you shouldn't
have less than 20 samples for a given
analyte because there are a lot of ways
that you can acquire samples and so you
know one of the most common ways is if
you're simply just switching platforms
you're going from one CMV quantitative
assay to another and you are likely
going to use your samples that were
tested on that previous method you can
also share samples between labs or
between colleagues
so I frequently you know if I want to
validate something we don't have or it's
a new transport media etc you know I'll
shoot my colleagues an email and ask if
they have specimens they can share you
can also use cat proficiency samples
some of the reference labs will actually
sell samples so once they're done past
their storage date you can purchase them
and they will give you the values to do
that so we've done that in the past and
then you can also spike samples as well
so I would not recommend doing your
entire validation verification using
spike samples because it doesn't close
as closely mimic human specimens but a
combination of these can be used
in addition to accuracy one of the
requirements for verification validation
is precision or reproducibility and
that's looking at if you take the same
sample and read it repeat it multiple
times does it still give the same result
and there's two types of precision
there's within run or intra assay
precision which is where you want to
test the specimen in multiples on one
run so you know at one point instead of
running it and single it run it and
duplicate triplicate etc and then
there's also enter at a precision which
is between run and so you want to take a
subset of those specimens and I should
should make a point of this you know
don't you might as well kill two birds
with one stone if you're already using
these samples for accuracy you don't
need separate samples for precision you
can you can use your accuracy samples
for precision so for inter inter assay
or between run precision you want to
test it on at least another day by a
different technologists and so you want
to do this also for each sample type
that you are validating or verifying so
run it one day wait a day or two have
another tech run it may be you know do
that a few times there's no defined
numbers for precision so there's nothing
saying oh you have to do three you have
to do twenty that's basically up to you
as a lab what you want to do and how
many you want to run for precision
another requirement for validation
verification is analytical sensitivity
or limit of detection and so per the all
common checklist LOD studies aren't
necessary for FDA approved or modified
tests I'm sorry that's a type of should
be FDA approved or cleared test but per
the microbiology checklist the LOD must
be verified or validated for all
quantitative tests so even though we got
away with it and all common the
microbiology checklist says that we have
to do it
it's a limit of detection studies the
limit of detection is defined as greater
than or equal to 95% of replicates are
detected so typically 20 specimens are
used as long as 19 of these are detected
you can say that that is the limit of
detection however if you run 20 samples
and more than one isn't detected you'll
have to increase your number or increase
your LOD some people will do less if the
they're running an fda-approved test if
they're staying on label they may just
run a few replicates to verify the
manufacturer's limit of detection and do
a more extensive limit of detection
study if it's off label or an LD T
analytical specificity or interference
testing is only required for FDU
modified and ldt so if you're using
fda-approved and you're sticking to
everything in the package insert you do
not have to perform analytical
specificity that's actually already
reported in the package insert and what
we do in those cases is we will actually
just copy the interferences that were
tested if we're staying on label and put
that in our verification summary
when you do this testing so the point of
analytical specificity or interference
testing is to ensure that related
analytes or foreign substances don't
interfere so for example if I keep going
back to CMV quants but primarily that
because that's the most widely used
quantitative assay but you know if
you're running it you decide to run it
in Boop on B ALS you want to make sure
that it doesn't interact or normal
respiratory flora don't interfere with
the assay and so you can perform these
studies yourself you know you can spike
high concentrations of organisms into
the specimen and run it and make sure it
doesn't interfere or if there are
published references you can caps as you
can cite those and if you do find any
interferences a lot of times there's not
but if you do you have to document that
and have a plan of action when they are
present
the reportable range is also required
for both fda-approved and FDA modified
LD TS and this is the range of values
that can be adequately or adequate
accurately measured by the test and so
when you're using your calibrators
that's really going to help guide or
establish your reportable range you want
to stay within kind of the highs and
lows of your calibrators so one of the
panels that we use for our calibrator
panels the lowest calibrator is 500 IU's
per mil or 2.7 logs and the highest is
5,000,000 so our range for that essay is
500 to 5,000,000 we found that it
performs accurately along that specific
range and you can put this either you
have to have it documented somewhere so
either in your validation or
verification in your op standard
operating procedure or some people also
will put the range on their report as
well that goes out into the electronic
medical record
you cannot report outside the range of
calibrators unless you validated that so
if you want a report so for example on
ours if we would get in the example I
mentioned above something that was
greater than five million we simply
report that as greater than five million
you can do further validation studies to
dilute a specimen so if it would come
back to dilute it and be able to give it
a specific value that does require
further validation but that does allow
you to report outside of the range of
those calibrators
once you have it validated you also want
to think about how you're going to
report your quantitative essay and one
of the big questions but really there's
not a good answer to is should
quantitative results be reported as
integers or log of values so integers is
just something you know like 321 or do
you want to put it and simplify it into
log values so there's arguments on both
sides of the situation here so integers
are easier for non laboratorians to
understand
I found that non laboratorians have a
difficult time grasping wood exactly the
log value is um however energy values
can cause over interpretation and I've
seen this on multiple occasions and so
an example of this would be if you have
a quantitative assay and you report you
know a hundred thousand copies per mill
you per mill whatever and then maybe
they run it again the following week and
now it's two hundred thousand and so
that looks really different it looks
like you've doubled your viral load but
depending on the specific assay that may
actually be within the variability or
the precision of that it may actually be
statistically equivalent and not
different but the physician will likely
look at that and think that the viral
load is increasing
I've given those and logs and values to
where guess it looks like it's going
from 5.0 to 5.3 but you could
potentially give them more guidance on
how to interpret a log of value
laug values in general allow providers
to more easily track trends so although
they often have a little bit of trouble
understanding what exactly a log value
is it is easier for them to look at and
track and so i've just given an example
here of two reports of five point one
two and three six point three four and
you can clearly tell the difference
there and could easily track it as
sequential viral loads are obtained
there are some integer values that i've
put here and I put it without commas
because one of our the previous EMR that
we used wasn't able to put commas in and
so potentially at first glance you may
not interpret these correctly it's
131,000 and then 2.1 million but you may
confuse those or the physician
interpreting the results may confuse
those because they're not easily
interpretable so there i should go back
there's not really a defined better or
worse and a lot of labs will report both
the integer value and the log value we
have switched over to reporting only the
log value which we did get a little
pushback at first but we you know
provided the physicians the information
with how much variability there was in
our assay so look for this much for it
to be considered a true change and
they've sent kind of adjusted to that so
but that's something to think about
before implementing it and how how
physicians look at it and how they
interpret it and there's no wrong or
right answer I think you could argue
either but you want to look at what's
most important or what what's most
helpful for your institution
another question that you will get is
what threshold or cutoff defines disease
and this is something clinicians often
want answered but we often don't have an
answer to and part of that is due to the
fact that viral loads vary within labs
in between labs and so a single assay
within a lab may bear may vary up to a
half a log or or more potentially and
may vary more than one log between labs
so that's tenfold difference so it's
hard to define a cutoff or a threshold
value when some of the viral loads vary
so significantly
the threshold that divide defines
disease varies by assay and often can
vary by patient so some exceptions are
things like HIV and the hepatitis
because if you have any amount of HIV
you have HIV disease but for other
things such as thinking about
epstein-barr virus and post transplant
with lymphoproliferative disorder
there's no definition or no cutoff of
this amount is what determines if the
patient has PT LD so there Studies on
that showing that you know maybe for
some patients it's a few hundred maybe
for some it's closer to ten thousand but
you will get questions and that's
something that you can't really answer
viral loads have also been shown to be
linked to drug regimens used for immuno
suppression so depending on what
chemotherapy he mont patient might be on
for example or if they change the drug
regimen it also can change the viral
load so that may be actually affecting
what is changing rather than the viral
load changing on its own
in general we we don't know what that
what the cutoff or the threshold is and
again you know our clinical colleagues
want a kind of a hard number of you know
this is what we're looking for but for a
lot of these assays we can't give them
an answer it's more about replicate
testing repeat testing and tracking the
trends instead
you
so once your assay is implemented you'll
want to think about Quality Assurance so
this is what CLIA refers to as
validation or ongoing assurance to make
sure that your assay is still performing
as expected
so now you've implemented an essay and
now what do you do so there's different
definitions for calibration and we'll
talk about those so we've talked about
calibration restore creating your
standard curve but if you will have one
of the platforms that allows you to
store your standard curves so I
mentioned we use the dsr molecular
liaison or instrument and we can store
our calibration curves for a long time
so what you'll then be required to do if
you're able to store your standard curve
is perform what's called a calibration
verification and this is just showing
that you know you've had that curve for
months that it's still performing as
expected and so then we'll talk about
the intervals for this but basically
confirming that your calibration
settings are still valid over time
there's also the analytical measurement
range or AMR and this is the range of
analyte values that a method can measure
directly without dilution or
concentration so as the example I gave
earlier the assay going from five
hundred to five million IU's per mil
that would be the analytical matter
measurement range and so one of the QA
requirements is to perform AMR
verification which is the process of
confirming that your range remains valid
and then there's recalibration which is
basically where you're creating a new
standard curve so following that initial
calibration procedure we talked about
and this is performed when either your
calibration verification or your AMR
verification fails again these if you
have an instrument where you have to
create a standard curve each day of
testing these QA measures are not going
to apply to you for calibration
verification acceptable materials must
be matrix appropriate and include you
can actually use the calibrators that
you use to make your initial standard
curve by running them as unknowns you
can use preferably a different lot
number but that doesn't always
necessarily have to be the case
materials provided by the vendor for
calibration verification you can use
previously previously tested patient
specimens that you know the values of
primary or secondary standards or
reference materials that are matrix
appropriate so again mimicking patient
specimens or proficiency testing
material it's specifically defined by
cap that you cannot use routine controls
for calibration verification and as with
a lot of the things that I've been
mentioning in this presentation
each lab has to define the limits for
accepting or rejecting the calibration
verification so you know you run your
calibration verification and you look at
the variation between your results and
what the expected results are but
there's no nobody out there defining
what that is for some of the
fda-approved assays they may have that
but for the most part like when we're
thinking about ASR is like with the DSR
in molecular instruments those are we
have to define the calibration
verification requirements or thresholds
ourselves and so that's put in a
procedure and if the calibration
verification fails then you must
recalibrate your curve
Amr verification may actually not be
required depending on how you're running
your specific tests so if when you run
your calibration verification you're
using low midpoint and high values near
the stadium AM are so near the high and
low and if your calibration verification
meet your acceptance criteria then you
actually don't have to perform a second
verification you don't have to do a
specific game or verification that's
already been met by your successful
calibration verification however if your
calibration verification materials do
not span the full Amr or the lab extends
it between beyond the manufactures
recommendation so for example if the
high end of our AMR is 5 million and
somebody has validated dilution beyond
that then you would have to do a
separate AMR verification to show that
you get adequate or accurate results
across the entire range of the AMR but
really for most labs a specific AMR
verification
won't be required because it will be
covered by a calibration verification
acceptable materials for AMR
verification include again they should
be matrix appropriate but linearity
material so cap does have a linearity
panel for some of the viral load tests
that you can use proficiency testing
material previously tested patients
primary or secondary standards
calibrators or basically the difference
between those and calibration
verification is that you can also use
control materials if they adequately
span the AMR
and as with calibration verification
each lab has to define the limits for
accepting or rejecting Amr verification
results so for example you may
during validation realize that the
variation in your test is let's say
point 3 log so it might be that you're
when you're doing your calibration
verification Amr verification the
unknowns have to fall within point three
log of your knowns so something like
that but you do have to define the
actual limits
the as far as the interval or how often
you have to do this calibration
verification and AMR verification must
be performed at least once every six
months so if you were allowed if you can
on your instrument to store a standard
curve you can store it for up to six
months or longer if your calibration
verification is successful you also must
perform a calibration verification and
potentially AMR verification when
there's any changes in major system
components so if you have an engineer
come in and replace a part for example
and also at reagent lot changes so what
we try to do is order reagents enough
reagent to get us to six months if you
order your reagents more frequently
every month or so you're going to have
to do calibration verification as often
as the reagents show up so we try and
order about six months of Regents at a
time so that we're only doing
calibration verification around the
six-month requirements
and again the acceptability criteria
must be established by the lab in
addition to calibration verification AMR
verification one of the requirements as
well for ongoing Quality Assurance is
what's called comparability of
instruments so if the lab uses more than
one instrument or method to test for a
given analyte those have to be compared
against each other at least twice a year
so this could be for example just say
CMC quant if you have two instruments
that run it even same manufacturer same
platform those have to be compared if
for whatever reason you run CMV quants
on two different manufacturer if two
instruments by different manufacturers
those have to be compared as well as far
as what you can use for comparability
studies if you are only testing the same
in on the same instrument platform so
for example if you use the dias or
molecular liaison instrument and you
have you know two of them three of them
but it's all on the same instrument
platform you can actually use quality
control data as your comparability data
as long as the reagents are of the same
manufacturer on lot number you actually
can just use the quality control data
that from your daily runs to compare and
show that the instruments are comparable
you also if it's the same platform or if
you have different platforms you can
also use him human specimens these are
performed worse stabilized controls so
that it's more similar to kind of use
the same as your human samples and avoid
any potential matrix effects so when we
do comparability of instrument
instruments we use primarily human
samples
as with many of the other things in this
talk the acceptability criteria are not
defined by regulations nor are the
amount of samples that you have to test
or how many quality control data points
so nobody has put a definition on this
cap has not said you know that you need
a specific number of QC points or that
you need a specific number of human
samples so that is up to you in the lab
but you do have to define it and have
that in a procedure defining what you're
going to run and how many of what you're
going to run
so we've covered a lot today and this
talk and the basic conclusion is that
you know there's a lot of regulatory and
standards requirements as far as
verification and validation and Quality
Assurance and the lab so it gets very
complex and often gets you know causes
confusion I've gotten a lot of questions
from from colleagues and lab techs about
you know why do we have to do this where
is this defined what do we do with this
and they are complex but don't be afraid
consult your cap chest checklist
frequently they are very well defined
there and with time cap has gotten very
or more specific with their requirements
and more defined so it's easier to
understand and don't be afraid to
consult colleagues who have experience
and ask them if you do have questions
and I put an important point here that
this includes chemists so we don't often
think of consulting with chemists in the
microbiology lab but they validate and
verify quantitative tests all the time
essentially most of their tests are
quantitative so they are a great
resource if you have a chemist in your
lab even you can ask questions there if
you make sure that your lab has all of
the following you will be just fine and
not have to worry about it so even
though it's complex there's a few things
that you'll need so if you have your
verification validation summaries signed
by the medical director with supporting
data you'll want to have that and make
sure you keep those for up to four at
least two years after the assay is
finished or not being used I'm going to
make sure you have test procedures for
all of your your specific assays that
you're running
make sure you have reliable calibration
materials to minimize variation and
minimize QC failures
and make sure that you have a procedure
either in your specific test procedure
or have a specific procedure for how
you're going to perform calibration
verification EMR verification if
necessary and recalibration make sure
you have you know what samples or what
calibration panel you're using what the
acceptability criteria are for that and
what you're going to do if it fails
that's one of the big things as that cap
doesn't specify you know the
acceptability criteria but you must have
them and you must develop them as a lab
so if you hell of all that you'll be
just fine it's not it's not as hard as
it seems once you get going it gets a
little easier I've included some
references and resources here if you
have further questions so the cap
checklist the ones that I have included
in numbers from are the 2018 versions so
there's the all common which are the co
M standards and the M IC standards are
from the microbiology checklist I've
also included a link if you're
interested in going to the clear
requirements in the Code of Federal
Regulations you can read through those
at your leisure if you're interested and
then don't forget that you can reach out
to colleagues so you know there is the
amp listserv there's the division C
listserv in microbiology
you can email other friends and
colleagues and don't forget that you can
ask your chemists as well and with that
I'd be happy to take any questions thank
you thank you dr. pence for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank the asur and molecular for
making today's educational webcast
possible as a final reminder our speaker
will follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we will see
you next time goodbye